ich bin in berlin wo hinter mir
franziska gefahr im rahmen des
weltfrauentags den müll entsorgt die
gleichberechtigung
ich weiß nicht ob ich in so einer
männerdominierten branche wie der
müllabfuhr arbeiten könnte ich meine der
gestank die ganzen schmatzende geräusche
die braune suppe die dig niedrigen decke
runter tropft und dort auch noch der
müll
[Musik]
sie sind zwei werke aus dem heidekreis
ist das der richtige begriff müllwerkern
warum nicht müllmenge rind das weiß ich
auch nicht
weltfrauentag wird hier zelebriert was
machen sie am weltfrauentag also erst
mal wenn ich ausschlafen dann er wodka
tampons oder klassischen rotoren hinter
die binde kippen
vielleicht liege ich auch mein glas
rotwein und wir haben auch schon heute
vom von unserem geschäft hose bekommen
von frauentag kennt ihr das wenn ihr zum
fototermin kommt und alle haben dasselbe
outfit abend ich hasse das
die müllabfuhr ist eine der wenigen
branchen die sich aktiv für eine
frauenquote einsetzt was tut man dafür
schlüssel daraus mehr müll machen für
den feminismus
also ich finde so allgemein kann man das
nicht sagen ich finde wir müssen schon
klar sagen in den vorstandsetagen den
chefetagen der deutschen unternehmen
sind im moment viel zu wenig frauen pakt
ist ja die sechs prozent frauen die
daran gekommen sind muss wahrscheinlich
viel viel mehr leisten als männer die da
so nachdem thomas kreislauf hingekommen
sind wir haben ja mehr thomas und
michael in deutschen chefetagen als
frauen sollte man seine tochter thomas
oder michael würde ich nicht gehen aber
wir müssen den thomas kreislauf
durchbrechen was könnten sie besser wenn
sie ein mann wäre ach wissen sie ich bin
ganz froh eine frau zu sein für mich ist
es viel wichtiger zu zeigen dass frauen
alles können also ich glaube ich könnte
als man auf jeden fall eine aufregendere
antwort aus sieben rausquetschen auch
wirklich ja orange drei sachen passend
zu dieser farbe zdf cdu und müll ist bei
mir diese aber sie jetzt nicht so
aufgeregt lachen das hat einen mann
geschrieben ja aber man kann ja auch
noch über männer wird zu lachen oder
apropos lachen am abend lädt peter
altmaier die weibliche wirtschafts elite
zum gespräch ein
haben sie die podiumsdiskussion genossen
oder haben sie sich hier gelangen wollte
streckenweise ganz unterhaltsam und ganz
spannend wo sich ehrlicherweise sagen
damit hatte ich gar nicht gerechnet aber
nochmal gut getan von den vier kindern
weg zu sein oder sozusagen warme wetter
abend mit ganz andere diskussion
anstatt mama wieso kriege ich keiner ist
so herr altmaier wieso finde ich nicht
mehr lohnen so wussten sie dass die zwei
länder mit den meisten
führungspositionen die durch frauen
besetzt sind schweden und finnland sind
ich hab das glaube ich mal gelesen ja
denken sie dass deswegen dort so viele
depressive alkoholiker leben wie feiern
sie den weltfrauentag
ich feiere ihnen gar nicht also ich
finde es weil ich quatsche die feier zu
müssen uns gibt und das ist gut so und
dafür konnten wir uns eigentlich jeder
feier in berlin ist der weltfrauentag
jetzt so ein gesetzlicher feiertag das
heißt weder die männer noch die frauen
arbeiten also beide verdienen für einen
tag genau gleich viel ist so cool also
sie sind entweder ein mann oder wirklich
eine sehr starke frau
ja ich bin eine junge frau ich bin
selbstständig erwerben was haben sie für
einen tipp für meine karriere
seien sie selbstbewusst und kämpfen sie
um ihren erfolg sie werben mit
chancengleichheit als wirtschaftsfaktor
sind meine chancen nur eine weitere
ressource für sie nein die
gleichberechtigung steht ja im
grundgesetz sie ist nur nicht bis heute
verwirklicht
das ist sozusagen der kampf der seit
vielen jahren und jahrzehnten
ausgetragen wird
diese nackte frauen oder die männer
sondern wir alle zusammen glaube ich und
es nutzt ja überhaupt gar nichts jetzt
sich gegenseitig vorwürfe zu machen
wir müssen schauen wie wir das ändern
können ich glaube dass wir in dieser
diskussion uns deshalb noch befinden
wir sind die erste partei die eine frau
als bundeskanzlerin hat keine kramp
karrenbauer ist jetzt unsere
parteivorsitzende auch das ist ein
signal
und darauf bin ich stolz ja super also
wenn die worte alt und eier auch in
meinem namen vertreten werden
dann könnte auch ich so eine billige
antwort geben und damit zurück
altmaier sagte altmaier